welcome back to a new rock stars news
everyone happy new year now recently
we're looking ahead to 2019 with the
super good business people that we are
and we realized something
2019 is gonna be freaking nuts yeah it's
huge new movies like every property is
something epic happening Avengers in
game of course is coming but also Star
Wars Episode nine it's coming at the end
of the year Game of Thrones is coming to
an end and it's not like Rick and Morty
is coming back to every every property
that you might be interested in has
something huge happen every property
every property so we decided together a
special 2019 preview episode for you
guys so we can all share the hype sound
good yeah I'm Erik Bosse joining me
today are Philip Malina Sam bachelor and
Maude Garrett thank you now let's do it
okay obviously because we are this
channel and because this is our world we
have to start with the MCU they've been
building up to this ultimate for so long
they ended infinity war obviously on the
biggest flip anger that I think has ever
happened in movies yeah there was
Breaking Dawn pot we're gonna get none
of that instead we're getting Captain
Marvel Avengers endgame and Turkey same
here for Marvel to see any think I mean
is this our new normal or is 2019 be
like ultimate apex of this whole thing
either way we talked about this movies
at four I mean not even just a year more
than a year now we're going to continue
to do so non-stop until the day they
released and then we'll release like
little theories about each one as they
as we come up with whatever we want just
don't get away from this channel okay
right but okay I want to like focus our
conversations as we've said so many
things about these already so we need to
just make some predictions and we're
gonna put money on these real hardcore
fake money all right
about what we think is gonna happen in
the rematch with Thanos phase 4 all of
these things so make it nice and simple
in the MCU we'll call it the new class
so this new phase
first off just I just want to know who
are the New Avengers who makes up the
roster of the Avengers right now and
who's in charge is it be it I think it's
yeah I think we've had conversations
about this before right like how could
they top phase three how could they top
the infinity war storyline the endgame
storyline it's so climactic it's been
you know over ten years in the making
and then I think if we just realized now
that they have the x-men Marvel
properties back under the Disney family
umbrella and you have potentially
Deadpool coming back spider-man if you
continue this partnership with Sony
you're talking about between spider-man
and Deadpool in the x-men the most
popular Marvel Comics characters before
the Avengers movies came out it's really
like Kevin Feige dream scenario to have
all these back so are you pitching
actually is not that they will be the
Avengers but the new replacement for the
Avengers will be the x-men movies I
think so that's how I would prefer it I
don't know I to keep making like mantle
yeah I kind of wanted to come to an end
yeah like at least two other team names
that they could play with over at
marbles I like the idea of doing young I
like a younger like skewed of an team
like I'd like to have like right now
they have the champions and you got your
Miss Marvel you got your Nova you got
your Miles Morales and that's a really
fun team they could play with you could
do Marvel Knights and you could have
like more adult-oriented characters or
you just do the x-men or the Fantastic
Four because it's like you have plenty
of characters that you no one's touched
in any of the movies or TV shows that
you could play with as well but when it
comes to like who's leading the Avengers
like that team you're getting I think
you could also re revamp them they did
this for a little bit called The
Ultimates then you could do it with
Captain Marvel who's on that team Black
Panthers on that team and then there's a
bunch of other like people who kind of
step in every once in a while like
Thor's been on that team also that was
the name of the Avengers when it was in
the Ultimate Comics so you could
basically pull anybody you want make
that that team and Thor had that weird
like chess plate that was like nipples
oh yeah
milk thought hey think about it from a
Hollywood casting point of view so who
the actors that are kind of new enough
in their career but the established
characters that can really elevate the
Marvel property so you like some Sheree
you know she's an actress who's done a
handful of things but she's not a DJ
expensive at this stage and I'm thinking
like they're going to handpick these
characters and they might not play the
rules of a previous comic book series
because all the properties are now
available so they're gonna actually pick
their own sort of like chess team I
could have said final football fantasy
football what do you know final football
is the term that Americans that's why I
don't talk broad you look at the actors
who are playing it I know that it's
interchangeable because I've seen a you
know generations of actors play a few
particular characters so far but that's
how I think they're going to move
forward it's a money game so you think I
mean get them out of this just in yeah I
do I think that we we see the original
slate of the Avengers all basically
retiring after the it's like they're all
kind of done Chris Thames what's gonna
be done how DJ's gonna be done like
that's kind of like old fades moving
into the new phase but you know you when
you look at the group build
you need someone that's got the dollars
you need someone who's got the
technology advances who's like super
smart
you need this strong person like that's
how I think they're gonna build it out
hence Sheree is untouchable cool I have
a question for you guys with you know
the current lineup of the Marvel movies
coming to an end with the Avengers saga
pretty much wrapping up and then you
have Game of Thrones ending up ending
and then you have the Star Wars Episode
nine final chapter the last Star Wars
movie ever final star was but of course
these brands aren't gonna end they're
gonna continue to spin off another
direction do you guys think that what
the what we currently love about these
movies might have been lightning in a
bottle for each of these studios and
they're not
Peter bull or do you think my opinion
with Robert Downey jr. part of the
success of Ironman was to see Robert
Downey jr. have a career again
he was just like kind of washed-up actor
who has had some fun roles how many
people was Ironman their first
introduction to Robert Downey jr. they
didn't know that he had had a past I
think you're right we are in this stage
where every year you're getting the next
one and next way you don't get a chance
to miss it there's no sense of nostalgia
anymore it's kind of like we're we're
we're kind of satiated by a lot of these
series at the moment and we just need to
take a little break I think that is
gonna happen but I do think in terms of
like is it lightening their bottle I
think no it's about growing up with
something and then you're excited for
right if you grew up with Ironman then
when he teams up with Captain America
and when he teams up with all of that
for that first cast you're like holy
crap that spin shot in the first
Avengers movie we all like can picture
it right now because that we've built up
to that moment but they can just do that
again they can do with the x-men they
can do it in ways that they kind of
surprised us like the Illuminati or
something where they you know we don't
even realize that they've established
all these characters and then they throw
a team movie at us or something I mean I
think that it's honestly Marvel has it
figured out so well I think gonna be
easy for them to Canada yeah it's a good
point also reinvented cuz like with Sony
it's like I mean I'm done with like this
big Venom's and the stuff like that like
it's venom wasn't awful but it wasn't
like stellar like I I don't really want
to invest more time in and then
spider-verse came out I was like oh this
is what you do it you don't literally
just ignore everything and just keep
doing this it's it's so inventive you
really like push the boundaries of
literally every aspect of this movie
from the cast of the animation of the
music everything like do that and I feel
like the MCU should woods can see that
and possibly like take a page out of a
book and do like an animated like yeah
movie I think it would I think it would
work if you wanted to again I think
younger heroes would be a fun way to
like get younger generations invested as
well but also it's kind of like that
Pixar formula where like there something
there for the adults as well do that
yeah it's definitely a good way forward
if you look at what they've done it was
only a couple years after Andrew
Garfield ended up with a character we
all thought we were done with spider-man
and then we saw Tom Holland on screen
and we're like oh no that's fine just
keep giving me more spite I mean in
Spider it might be a unique character
because he's the most popular right
around Batman are probably easiest to
reinvent
you know it has a lot to do with the
mask honestly oh yeah that makes sense
but there's definitely some
experimentation we've done and
especially if you have infinite
directions like into the spider purse
yeah but let's move to like some other
because it's not just like these big
tent pole movies I'll talk about the
other ones before we get to that you
actually want to get to our trivia
question let's ask the question I love
that you're immortalized as your hot dog
shot okay here we go this is an
interesting question
the original Blade Runner is set in the
year 2019 named one of the movie filmed
in the past but set in the future of
2019 okay so all of our answers are here
in the bin and always the loser as
decided by our judges will have to reach
the targets of shame vessel here for arc
and have to join our other exciting
things happening in the year 2019 yeah
we've got other movies coming out this
year there's a lot happening a ton one
might actually say we've got glass like
I may be the second pot duck Phoenix
Shazam detective Pikachu the live-action
Aladdin the live-action Lion King
Godzilla king of monsters around so
sorry for the New Mutants it's chapter
two not IT chapter two which is the
movie better broken computer
[Laughter]
at least we have Star Wars this one it
seems like the most traction happening
you know at the moment cuz the movies
coming out soon is chosen yeah yeah a
lot of stuff at Comic Con last year I
think that one's gonna be a lot of fun
we've got a gal gadot as one woman again
first movie was great
someone's probably almost who doc
Phoenix I'm on the fence about and it
hurts my but I've heard good and bad so
maybe in the middle
Godzilla there you see those monsters
who doesn't love them all of those
trailers yeah yeah
anyway Lion King has got Beyonce so
you are most excited for start with you
female I'm the add one okay I this isn't
necessarily the one of the most society
for all tossed about later maybe the
thing I'm just the most curious about
what is up with the Toy Story for things
11 I'm still like yeah what is this
gonna be it's gonna change cinema do you
guys know one they said the Tom Hanks
has been talking yeah yeah yeah they are
gonna make everyone loved two things
that go hand in hand in my nightmares so
yeah I genuinely just want to know not
only like where they can take that story
but it kind of the way that James
Cameron talked about how avatar was
gonna change you know film and then they
don't he only meant for himself video
game since no has actually happier when
they did create that awful trip every
movie being 3d for like four years it's
like I guess I got to pay four dollars
me what's it called Clash of the Titans
with Liam Neeson's hair popping out for
no reason I'm just mad because it does a
sponsored by avatar
alright but I that's thing I'm a setback
somebody throw out what you think it's
gonna be the test very forward thing um
it we're a character you know I think
it's gonna ask kids to be to think
existentially I just think it's like
he's kind of rounding up with what the
actual excitement will be it's gonna be
a very profound children's movie in ways
that previous movies haven't been which
is a high bar to clear if you think what
Toy Story you yeah when they burn them
all I've melted it I walked out kids are
gonna fully understand death and like
the end they're gonna get it finally
over here let's explain death to kids
yeah
we're gonna actually finally explain the
anatomy of the slinky dog and what is
your most exciting title I mean I think
this is weirdly going to be the year of
live-action Disney we have three coming
out this year that Aladdin Kingdom
Aladdin the king of monsters
Dumbo king of the monsters and in Lion
King I mean art yeah it's John Oliver's
gonna wear a beak but I'm most excited
about just based off of like the
trailers it's probably Godzilla King
because that's what like a franchise we
kind of forget exists but like every
single one of those movies well there's
been two I've really enjoyed like I
really enjoyed the game like the last
one I like Skull Island a lot and it's
it's kind of came and went I watched on
my college I think is it I guess you are
you're trying to say like this universe
of movies yeah this new relaunch of yeah
the Godzilla with Matthew Broderick in
98 really movie well I'm also
referencing the one with with Heisenberg
Edwards one I thought well the ending
was really it's kinda like broke one for
me like the whole movie was kind of like
okay where are we going and in the last
10 minutes are amazing and it's all I
remember and that's the whole movie
forever and ever
finally it is something that like
everyone in the mood there's everyone is
in the movie right they have like 20
amazing actors and it's like I don't
know how they're gonna keep that scale
but I'm excited to see it I think it's
gonna determine whether or not Millie
Millie Bobby Brown is going to be like
you know the next Natalie Portman like
jobs Nara turned huge or if she's gonna
exactly play this one role where it's a
little girl that screams hates her own
scream yeah for me no it's detective
Pikachu because it's such a weird it's a
weird live-action property to do and it
has a really there's a lot to get wrong
like a lot like it's
there's it's just weird because it's
like it could it looks great right now
it looks really inventive and it looks
like it can be a lot of fun it's a new
world for like kids and adults like
rediscover stuff that they love but also
these are characters that aren't meant
to be
live-action they're not meant to be
something that I can fully understand
walking around like mr. mime that's a
because he has a prefix yeah he has
balls and shoulders it's confusing he's
got like rubber all over him it's it's
weird um but I'm excited to see what
they can make with that Avengers of
course I'm gonna be excited for but for
other movie zombie land too that's still
in production right now it's supposed to
come out next year I'm very excited
about that this yes writing next year on
your chest yeah you know I'm I'm
actually super excited about that I want
and I Dumbo's up there because I've
never seen the other one I everyone kind
of knows what happens in DUMBO I've
never seen the animated one and I and it
looks like a Tim Burton movie that can
actually get like a lot of his I'm
actually now a majority of his movies
have kind of let me down which really
bums me out and it seems like something
that has a lot of heart that I can get
invested in and I want to see that and
you got Danny DeVito and Danny DeVito
and somehow is not a detective Pikachu I
know he was supposed to be yeah that's
true I have to agree with you about
detective Pikachu there's a lot of risk
happening here like there's a lot at
stake and this if you're talking about
changing cinema which Toy Story for
believes it's gonna do I feel like this
is how you do it you just throw so many
curveballs and it's like the most
ridiculous thing out there and then if
it can work then yeah you're kind of
changing what what potential cinema has
afterwards or ideas and constructs when
you guys are time I play pick at you and
it detective Pikachu and making it like
you know this crazy thing do you kind of
just mean like in the Who Framed Roger
Rabbit kind of way it's just weird
because they're trying to like make this
whole world really work because like in
like Who Framed Roger Rabbit it's like
there's toontown and then there's real
world and we kind of interact sometimes
but don't really like each other so if
if weird stuff happens it's kind of near
the border but this is like everything's
together and it needs to work but I
think this is the best way to do it
because mod you're right it's like we
connect we can poke fun at this but we
can also like show how this world works
and like Pokemon battles and like being
a trainer and everything like that
there's a lot to make this world make
more
sense and move forward and make that one
I feel like Pokemon has been just
breaking down barriers and reinventing
itself so successfully over decades now
this going into film instead of being
animated only and having an a-list name
like Ryan Reynolds attached to it is
just like blasting you know it was
accidentally a team rocket this whole
thing just for you to get to can you
just well because that's how I feel
about a young Young Justice is coming
out and there's that said Joker glacier
it's really not freaking out about it's
at nine still here away carrie fisher's
characters still like that is she should
have been handled a night and
respectfully I feel and I think it's
also don't know how you wrap all this up
I don't and I don't hate States two
people trying to tell the same story but
using very different words in uh when I
was in at my high school prom there was
this kid who was like very meek and he
leaned into me and he said I've been
working on my breakdancing do you think
I should premiere it here on the dance
floor and I was like no this could not
go well and I just had this dread
feeling that I kind of had for episode 9
but then he went and he killed it yeah I
did a great job yeah no I hear you
saying yeah it is something that like
that the stakes are very high
but it's JJ Abrams getting back in
control of the worlds or the new chapter
the world that he started so and Shazam
I'm really excited for I'll throw that
out there Shazam looks like it's gonna
be a ball of fun and he's gonna be a
breath of fresh air for DC yeah I
predict that we're gonna hear something
big about DC this year that's just kind
of like somebody hits a big ol reset
button there's something like that yeah
same yeah or like they just bring him
like you know what we don't care about
James Gunn's issues he's taking over our
whole universe
she's gonna marry Kevin five years and
then yeah yeah interesting and bright
burn looks really exciting to his bright
burn coming out this year in 2020 do you
know yeah yeah probably this year that's
the essentially what the real Superman
would be like yeah let's not forget
about new goodies like Rick and Morty
season four new episodes on the way they
drop that awesome EDM themed teaser
recently they got everybody excited I
was a big fan of it also we got stranger
things coming this summer someone
noticed a stunt man credited on IMDB as
playing a Russian guard so I'm curious
to know how that's going to you know
yeah things out in Indiana all of our
favorite Arab air shows our back my
favorite shows culminating into crisis
on Infinite Earths that's so cool I
really hope they bring on Tom Welling I
fingers crossed if we're gonna be
getting another season of Jessica Jones
and Punisher and of course we have
Watchmen from home
Lindelof it's coming to HBO we'll see
how that turns out and then of course
little show name Game of Thrones it's
gonna have its final season this year
that's gonna be crazy let's talk
predictions we're not moving from this
segment where I stay right here until
we're done everyone's gonna give me the
biggest TV prediction you could possibly
come up with and I will let you know if
it's big enough let's start with mutton
okay Gavin's friends we're gonna be
talking about they establish time travel
and the baby that was born to the night
king his where the white-eyes was
actually John and Danny's kid prediction
I've made this prediction before I think
bran will be revealed as the night king
I think that's a I think time travel
might go in that direction there's been
some clues right it wasn't he holdin
Funko pop toy of the night king and all
the other actors were holding ones of
their characters some reason he was so
in someone's like oh that was taken like
years ago and I was like I don't believe
you think I mean if I wanted a Funko pop
I wouldn't grab brands I grabbed the
honest theory hearing this Russian
soldier being cast in in stranger things
wouldn't be interesting if they revised
the timeline kind of do some historical
fiction but true fiction the way that
like inglorious bastards ended and
they're like no the timeline is actually
different in this 1980s world
had like the Cold War kind of in a Red
Dawn situation where the Russians invade
like a weekend the United States from
these interdimensional monsters and they
have to work together to fight them and
kind of watchman scenario worlds are
colliding go ahead yes we go somewhere
they use the mind flayer to invade the
Soviet Union it's the big octopus
invades it gets in the boy's head name
yeah it's still alive yeah still there
he's still there we saw it last shot oh
my plays are really hard to play in D
and E it had to be done
we're any at least two more season to
figure it out for arrowverse I'm excited
to see Tom Welling and Michael Rosenbaum
come back cuz that's gonna be amazing
for Christ's on infrared oh where where
are we on rumors of that and and so
there was a photo posted on Stephen
amell's
Instagram that ended up just being a
promotion for his winery but I'm gonna
post the picture he's like big news
coming soon in whose picture Michael
Rosenbaum working at a table and then
like literally 30 minutes later it was
like they signed on to promote their own
wine here it's like no but honestly I
think that was just a tease that meaning
that we're gonna get those characters
probably up in crisis on Infinite Earths
I mean obviously multi dimensions and
all that multiverses but don't they
already have a Superman they do but they
introduced they introduced a couple that
basically you can play with the
multiverse also I think this is going to
be leading to Supergirl coming over to
like the main show so we don't have to
think about it she's on her own like on
our mansion thing and so is Black
Lightning I think they're gonna bring
that over they're gonna like just kind
of combine everything make it cleaning
concise also it's weird that they
announced it so early on that it's like
hey nerds you better be watching these
shows so that we can get renewed for
another season they're like we need all
of our characters to be on the air all
right you understand we need you guys to
watch so that when we get the ratings
and blah and I think that's why they're
announcing it so early on it's also
super exciting so excited to wear see
where that ends up and my big prediction
is when we get in Tom Welling and
Michael Rosenbaum but also I think
they're gonna be pulling some weird
actors from like the birds of prey TV
show okay and I think they're gonna be
pulling from Titans on DC Universe as
they talked about that and I was also
wondering like you know if they might
even play with like I mean they won't
but it'd be fun if like in the animated
movies
- reference to leave yeah like do team
the animated Teen Titans like do
something like do something crazy like
man remember how well going to comic-con
and I was on the train and I sat next to
the voice of Beast Boy you did it's
crazy because that's just what he sounds
yeah my voice a lot of these people have
like played like a lot of cares in DC
Universe okay for my prediction I'm
gonna jump outside just to the TV
landscape first okay I'm gonna say that
we're gonna hit a Netflix fatigue this
year that we're gonna kind of be a good
agree your necklace that I think it's
gonna lose all the Marvel stuff
including Punisher recently it was
reported that it actually wasn't marbled
I was saying that Netflix can't make
more daredevil it was Netflix saying
they didn't want to so I don't think
we're gonna get more Punisher and then I
started into and then I think we
actually are gonna jump on that new S
and it's gonna be the Disney Plus
service I think we're actually gonna be
having conversations and not very long
about like oh my god have you seen
whatever the mandalorian yeah Disney
Plus is gonna take over everything this
year I think yeah that's a really good
bit more money the most
on the nose prediction then that's
that's next year
mm-hmm but this will be the death of
Netflix this yeah I it's gonna lose a
little bit him I can see that happening
also Hulu maybe a little bit but yeah I
am excited to see we're all we're all
our new shows go
watchman could be I think it could
surprise this I mean Damon Lindelof is
someone who it's kind of been a mixed
bag for a lot of people haven't once
crazy about Prometheus and some of the
other things he's done but I think the
guy's good I mean lost was a really fun
show I stayed with it every season to
kind of sucked once they start going
crazy with lost which is where Damon
Lindelof stirred to have a lot of fun I
was on board I'd like to see his take on
Watchmen which he's it sounds like he's
doing a lot of new characters of the
exception a lot of Mandy is yeah that's
Jeremy I injure me I basically nailed
that I love Jeremy Ines I think that
could be the new I mean HBO wants it to
be the new like piece of IP that we're
all except we'll see cuz it reminds me a
little bit of the energy going into
American Gods with show time where it
was kind of like oh it's like adult but
at the same time like this like very
rich character universe and then they
kind of like overshot it a little bit
everyone left yeah that's the big
problem I would say the first season
American Gods is like perfectly but I
mean like in terms of it being
commercially successful it kind of like
didn't have a great audience target I'm
a little just worried about like where
Watson is targeted yeah I think the
biggest issue is there was I was on
Showtime
and they don't have like a ton of
subscribers I think if you release
American Gods as it was on HBO
understand but we definitely there's let
us know down the comments below if we
missed anything I know there's a lot of
TV shows and we probably overlooked some
but let us know what you're most looking
forward to in 2019 let us know your
biggest craziest prediction for shows
that you know what you would bet take
the one on it especially it Sam down in
the comments Breaking Bad movie sorry
breaking but also specifically do let us
know here also let us know on that
website where we take information what's
its downlink right here yeah but the
reason I ask is because we actually are
gonna be picking what we're gonna give
our attention to this year right around
now so if there is something that we
need to put on our radar and enough of
you say it then yeah well focus on it
yeah mod videos videos breaking down
mods emotional state this week on seven
last week it was worth so sevens good
drill sergeant videos yelling but now it
is time for us to move to New York
stores news lightning round
questions I'm gonna fire them at my
co-host myself and we have to answer as
quickly without hesitation as possible
ready hmm okay here we go mud at
sensitive wants to know who would be the
best comic book character or team slash
duo to host the Oscars I know I have to
go through who's funny and but who's a
good duo help Rick and Morty comic they
have a comic Booster Gold and Blue
Beetle yeah good bounce of each other
that no oil I'm gonna say two tick
remember how yeah but like early 90 is
not the recent very sure
yeah okay they go there's options around
at jets Jack Skinner for wants to know
what's your favorite or best podcast
that you listen to this year ooh the
habitat was the best one it was about
astronaut our astronauts and training
being locked in a habitat for one whole
year and it kind of turns in like the
real world is great it's like a reality
show for astronauts go listen to it
Philip at Sunday duck high wants to know
fast-forward 10 years what is your
mobile device able to do what does it
look like oh it can fold up and unfold
to whatever device display size you need
in that moment it can project and it can
wirelessly transfer things in a swipe
from one device to another device also
it's gonna scan your blood instead of
your face that's how you unlock your
phones like an AI companion that likes
to talk to us we don't only everyone at
Swift to here wants to know what is the
invention you're looking forward to the
most
okay does 1 invent at any point okay
this idea has already been mailed to
myself I have a patent on it or
something whatever but it's very
specific
it's an antigravity device which sounds
super made-up but I just mean as simple
as solving the problem that somehow we 7
2019 of putting something right there
okay does it make sense like for
instance you deal with the salon film
sets you need a light to be right there
so we have to rig a contraption that is
like a bunch of poles and put them
together like a little higher and now a
light can be there if we can just go
like there's like like those maggots are
super cooled so they're like
superconductors yeah things that let us
put something in a section of space and
just it stays there oh goody that's in
10 years time in this year I want a
martyr Home Companion that's like an
Alexa but has more personality I on
social media I have a
posted I have a little vector it's this
little robot that controls everything
like Amazon does but it has a
personality to it try to nail that try
to figure that out we're laughing
because Alexa is listening to us right
now and just really bad idea she can
roll around out easy things die hards
the best Christmas movie that's me
consult consolidate my xbox in my
playstation 4 die made me choose well I
don't want to bum anyone I'm Mitchell
I'm looking forward to the most is like
medical breakthroughs like I want like
they're on it seems like they're on the
cusp of like finding a fibers and it
sounds like they're making some major
headway with like finding some real
treatment for making a device not a
treatment they want a robot that leads
to and then you just trust to stay in
there yeah let him take the wheels
sometimes replacement I'd I saw someone
make this has a camera in it the feeds
in their brain the signal in their brain
was not very good but the signal to
their phone that looked really good that
he could pull up to his other eye was
really good well but not not crazy to
make its without brain cochlear implants
do that exact thing they enhance the
signal in yeah through an electronic
pulse and you hear sound oh they could
do with us better cochlear implants too
so it's not just one volume it's
actually there's some like dissonance
and stuff they're able to focus on
sounds instead of just taking everything
in yeah
oh and real life filters and we should
hundred percent be weaponizing bionic
prosthetics cuz I want oh yeah sure oh
my keys don't work blow the hole through
the door yeah I think it's you
altruistically I'm like how can we use
technology to prevent more forest fires
free actually for you didn't say beat up
hurricane that sounds cool checks my
social media feeds on my eyes okay and
then and I want more censoring from fake
news to get it out off of our social
media and ruining our lives
bring back hoverboards but they light on
fire less okay answers your question
hover
specifically for me at Brandon Burnie 12
wants to know will we see soul world was
so enlightening around an Avengers
endgame with all the characters who were
dusted yeah I think it wasn't there like
some image it might have just been fan
art that may that was made of all the
dusted characters with Gamora in that
orangie soul world place I mean the
brothers have said that that is soul
world so if we saw Gamora in there I
think
either we'll see them in that same place
or I have like another theory that will
see certain characters in different so
world dimensions within each of the
different sounds like an amazing theme
part Sam at red jello wants to know will
self-driving cars be something we
realistically have in the next five
years will be closer to 50 before there
is one in every driveway give it a 10
give it a nice 10 give it a 10 years
there you go that's and it's just gonna
it's the way I could improve like
traffic patterns and everything it'll
make things a lot safer for people yeah
yes everyone's car will be able to sell
job they just won't choose to yeah and
then a mod Sonny duck wants to know
predict your favorite movie of this year
2019 what will be your favorite movie my
mouth disappeared yeah yeah
philip @s Jemma one wants to know when
are the next updates on scene are coming
oh well what week is this what am I
allowed to say there's very cool updates
actually right now so whenever this airs
I'll tweet them but there's a really
cool stuff where I can tell you this now
actually you can now do essentially kind
of like a group face time with your
friends and hang out and watch Netflix
together right now yeah on Twitter yeah
and you can also do it with some
influencers and stuff too so that part
I'll get to later oh yeah awesome that's
fun and then finally at gun four is
asking how will of enters in game impact
guardians of the galaxy vol 3
I think it'll happen they have Italy and
too many months now and there's a 62
timeline you can say that about Dark
Phoenix dude I will maybe so I went away
I don't think it will I think we'll see
some stuff with Avengers in game or
restores or resets a lot of things for
characters who they want to build a
future out of like spider-man like Black
Panther Doctor Strange
I think the guardians will be mixed in
with that too I think the guardians who
they want to continue working with will
see maybe maybe David Bautista doesn't
want to do it and the James Gunn isn't
on board but yeah I think the guardians
are probably gonna make this make it out
of endgame okay for everyone what is
something that personally you're looking
forward to happening for you in 2019
interesting I were working out nice
thanks everybody
I think you're working out here I am
thank you or making a work it's okay I
one thing I'm excited about working on
is a way cuz I saw last year I was doing
like my infinity fan live shows and it's
just kind of an experiment to see if I
can like harness the love of all comic
related things and mix it with like my
love of comedy and live performance and
I kind of want to do like a regular
thing and kind of you know if you
familiar with the LA comedy scene
there's this thing called like nerd meld
and and nerdmelt comics and they had
this like great community of like
comedians that was in the back room of a
comic book store and that had to shut
down because they they lost the lease on
the space yeah Harmon quest was there is
such a great podcast show so there's
there's a lot of things that they kind
of had to find new homes I'm interested
in trying to restart something like that
there's a store right down the street
for me and there's like the theater they
go to that's right next door to it so
just know a different kind of book story
that's that's right yeah so we'll see
keep forgiving little girl I'm getting
my green card this year
I know and it's not because I'm marrying
anyone I'm doing it all by myself
yeah yay great dope use your flash and
sometimes you like check it out it takes
you have to take a citizenship test no
that's just her to become a citizen yes
yeah almost look with you anyway I won't
know any pledge allegiance go yeah how
many squares are on destroy American
citizens we'll probably good I'm excited
for I'm on this huge self-betterment
kick I like I'm taking classes in like
cooking and fighting and fighting in the
kitchen but aside from all that none I'm
really excited about there's a couple of
like projects that I could make their
way to a medium outside of the internet
well this all sounds great this actually
feeds right into her 15-second shout
outs so we kind of shout out what we're
excited about what about right now what
are some things that we want to shout
out and let people know you should run
over to gamma ray on YouTube I do a show
called rude gamer and I got a play I was
playing The Walking Dead telltale games
and I had to pick all the wrong
decisions and lots of chili and a whole
during the entire invasion if you want
to see me do that go watch that and give
a little subscribe chaotic even launched
a fashion line called what which is WH
UT and this is one of them so if you
like cool designs and comfy clothes that
are good quality and handmade in
California nice and ethically I jump on
to shop what calm that's all thanks yeah
made fun of it earlier but it's actually
really cold there hoodie dresses like
these with the kangaroo pouch to show
where she's from it's fun because it is
only right now around I can start
mention it so let's give another shout
out to senior I'll do a specific link on
my Twitter of where which version I'm
talking about but I think that is so
cool that you can just like being your
long-distance relationship and not have
to countdown 3 2 1 to hit
to try to watch the Americans whatever
show it is that you're watching that's
cute
yeah it's very cute so use it and I'll
give a shout out to what's my new
Twitter account that I'm loving followed
now if I shout out Pokemon facts before
it backs our contacts gets another shot
it's so Pokemon facts makes me happy
well alright so these are great shout
outs
yeah great shout outs let us know your
shout out no don't shout things out me
at me let's return to our trivia answer
the loser of the gif of shame Club that
question was in the original blade
runner.the it was set in the year 2019
named one of their film that was filmed
in the past that takes place in the
future of 2019 takes place this year but
it was shot I think I'm around the same
as you though it's a lot further in the
future than we mod said Fifth Element
though it's just which feels like a
20-19 it feels like maybe a 2025 it's
like it's like a no it's like a 21 yeah
23rd century 2390 I just wanted us to
talk about one of my favorite movies I
love that I love honestly more Chris
Tucker's character your sucker it's ism
it's Russia he's making references to
like Lionel Richie but it's the 23rd
century like why would he know fimA said
Minority Report
[Music]
they drive Lexington's in that movie
we're getting shot down pretty great
took had made two guesses because he's
so scared of what's in his box
so guest number 1 Judge Dredd and guest
number two escape from LA not New York
I think la might have been disqualified
for having two answers you selfie yeah
there's no movie called Judge Dredd -
escape judges 20/80 and escape from LA I
think he's pretty pretty close
oh yeah they're looking at that mine's
20 2013 right there yeah they had a
pretty good estimate in 2009 was gonna
be like in 10 years time so I think I
was pretty close you know Wally do you
know when Wally was supposed to take
place Evie Wally might have been a
couple hundred years - no no no no no no
seven hundred years ago seven hundred
years from win though by the end they
start recreating Leonardo DiCaprio art
you know and I think that sounds like a
no the correct answers there are several
correct answers the island that was the
Ewan McGregor with clones the road
Daybreakers also new barbarian steel
frontier in Heatseeker the island the
road Daybreakers new barbarian steel
frontier in heat C 29th century when I
was only the 23rd century so
boom so Philip got pretty close already
report and my second answer was pretty
close
well he could broke too though that's
cheating that's cheating you over show
you say with me that was a Price is
Right six years ago sophie was our
winner and the exam away for seven
hundred years is a great you think okay
you think in the time that Wally came
out they thought by now we would all
have left earth children's movie by the
way it's fiction I'd like by the time
you're in high school earth is dead I
made it in the year 2007 calms 12 years
Hosko rules the world it makes sense it
lines up pretty close to today cuz goes
one of the juggernauts of gap yet it you
got a membership okay great savings
Phillips gonna read her goodbye Sam is
gonna join our gift for shame
[Music]
Buffalo Bill dance from Silence of the
Lambs
what is the Buffalo Bill you know is
that the pellet the tuk-tuk yeah and the
weird and then I would enjoy my own time
and then will sing my horses I am not
familiar with this I'll do my best with
that alright I'll be cut most of the
awkwardness out because they're the
things got weird in here he did this
first without clothes but he's still
committed so give it up for Sam hey Sam
that shame on Eric for making Sam to
cross things outside of his dreams but
make sure to comment down below about
the things you're excited about in 2019
I want to thank our host Eric Foss you
can follow him at EA vas Sam basher at
Sam basher Maude Garrett at Maude
Garrett and Philip Malina at [ __ ] like
this video shared around subscribe to us
if you don't already how do you watch to
the end of this video and not subscribe
that's weird
see you next week bye
by